epic Transformations are a dime a dozen
Trope in anime together with the likes
of Shonen isakai's and dense Harem
protagonists they're often accompanied
by flashy visual effects dramatic music
and Powerful voice acting these
Transformations are so compelling
because they show the characters growth
potential and determination so without
further Ado let's talk about the top 10
transformations in anime released from
2020 to 2023 now if we're talking about
Transformations we can't avoid talking
about boruto
[Music]
you might be turned off right away
because of the mere mention of this but
I guarantee you this transformation is
one of the decent if not best moments in
the anime so far Marion mode works in a
similar way to nuclear fusion wherein
Naruto and kurama's chakra is consumed
to create power a large amount of
increase to even ishiki and Sasuke are
on edge Varian mode is one of the most
impressive and creative transformations
in Naruto's history it shows how far
Naruto and Kurama have come as partners
and friends and how much they're willing
to sacrifice for each other and for the
world Varian mode is a testament to
Naruto's bond with gurama as well as a
testament to how much his personality
has rubbed off on the nine-tailed Beast
all in all it's a great Showcase of a
last resort type of transformation and a
fitting send off to one of the main
characters of the franchise that's been
with us since the start
before we continue imagine this you've
just been escied into another world and
you have to build your own team of
Heroes to defeat the demon king and what
better way to learn all of that while
having fun with raid Shadow Legends the
sponsor of today's video you can collect
hundreds of Champions play both PVE and
PVP and best of all you're gonna have a
ton of fun but wait there's more the
Hydra Clan boss is here and ready to
fight you with its six heads and these
are the scariest ones first up we have
the suffering head which is basically an
UNO reverse card it has the ability to
share the damage it takes with you which
means the more damage you dish out the
more you receive next we have the head
of Torment which is probably one of the
worst opponents you could face when it
uses its ability called true fear you
and your team will skip turns and can't
even use your skills lastly there's the
head of Wrath which looks like the
dungeon boss from a fantasy anime the
worst thing about this one is that after
you hit it 15 times it activates a skill
known as Vengeance and its attack power
triples until the end of its turn Hydra
Clash is a new Clan based company
petition where you and four other clans
see who can smack a Hydra the hardest
there are sweet rewards on offer too so
rally your clan mates and get ready use
my link in the description or scan my QR
code to get insane bonuses we're talking
about an epic Champion Drake From The
Lizard Man faction and other useful
things like energy refills skilled homes
and XP boosters once you're in and
crushing your enemies come find me under
the name vinichu and if you're fast
enough you can join my clan so just hit
my link in the description and I'll see
you on the battlefield from war crime
slime we have mob's Herobrine Persona
going psycho in mob psycho 100.
mob suppressed Alter Ego is a
manifestation of mob's repressed psychic
power that's why it's capable of all the
feeds mob is capable of but on a much
greater and far more destructive level
for the third and final time this
repressed Persona surfaced after mob was
knocked out after being hit by a car on
his way to meet zubomi this Walking
Disaster traveled across various cities
to find tsubomi and Proclaim mob's love
for her simply by walking towards her he
destroyed nearly everything in his path
the various disasters it left in its
wake became increasingly devastating
from Simply destroying the ground nearby
trees and fences to obliterating
skyscrapers as well as causing
earthquakes and tornadoes final
transformation is why I personally
admire the way one the creator of mob
psycho and one punch man writes his
stories and characters being able to
grow and move past your insecurities by
accepting those flaws is honestly
inspiring it's a transformation that in
reality all of us will have to go
through in our lives mine is the part
where we create tornadoes and
earthquakes and stuff like that with
amazing visuals fight scenes and
character development for the final Arc
of the final season this transformation
became the Catalyst for the perfect
ending of a beloved series coming
up
the next entry on our list is after
reaching a new level in his demon form
while fighting Dante in Black Clover
the fight between Astor and Dante in
Black Clover anime is an intense and
epic battle before the series underwent
to Hiatus it showcases The Clash of two
devil hosts who have different levels of
control over their powers the fight
starts with Dante easily overpowering
Asta and his fellow black balls with his
gravity magic he reveals that he can use
up to 80 percent of his Devil's power
while Arthur can only use a fraction of
his anti-magic things get worse when
Dante impels Gauss with a huge Rock
triggering our star's rage and Awakening
a new form of his devil power astar's
arm transforms into a black claw with
spikes and he gains a horn and a wing on
his right side his speed and strength
increased dramatically even creating a
swirling black tornado to defend against
Dante's attacks Asda manages to land a
blow to Dante's face with a latter in
shock that his rabid opponent even
managed to predict his teleportation the
fight is a thrilling display of
Animation music and voice acting that
throws every shade of black at you it
also interacts with the viewer's
Curiosity about the power and abilities
of the other devil host of the Spade
Kingdom the answer of which will be
revealed after the Beloved series
finally returns
history repeats itself yet again with
this next entry Gohan versus Cell in the
recent Dragon Ball super superhero movie
now if we're going to have a list of
anime Transformations we can't forget
the Saiyans and their skill in growing
their hair and changing their hair color
when they scream almost two decades ago
Gohan defeated the perfect version of
cell now that another cell's returned
Gohan finally had the opportunity to
shine once again and remind viewers of
how much of a beast he is in combat I've
seen Piccolo getting brutally beaten by
cellmax the enraged Gohan transforms
into his Beast form Gohan Beast is an
evolved form of Gohan's potential
Unleashed State stemming from Gohan's
continued Awakening since he was a child
and is currently his strongest
transformation in this form he
effortlessly withstood and brutally
retaliated against a full power punch
from celmax with his Aura and was able
to completely annihilate his massive
energy sphere as well as his core with a
special beam Cannon while orange Piccolo
was restricting the Giant's movements
the film did Gohan Justice by finally
allowing him to stand on the same level
as his dad with his new transformation
the visuals and sound design of this
transformation are superb most notably
the new animations style that gives the
characters a more comic-like look with
tons of references to the first fight
between Gohan and cell long time fans
will surely appreciate this movie and
Gohan's new Evolution
[Applause]
[Music]
reaching The Stairway to Heaven next on
our list is made in heaven from Jojo
ah
every new season of Jojo just
automatically makes it into lists partly
because I don't want to piss off JoJo
fans but also because every stand
evolution is so memorable it turns into
memes one of the most mind-blowing
moments in JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
Stone ocean is the first appearance of
made in heaven the ultimate stand of
Enrico Pucci made in heaven is a stand
that can manipulate time and gravity
accelerating the flow of time for
everything except its user and those who
are close to him this allows Pucci to
achieve the goal of resetting the
universe and creating a new world where
everyone knows their fate the first
glimpse of made in heaven is when Jolin
and her allies notice that the sky is
changing rapidly and their movements are
becoming slower and slower they realize
that Pucci has reached the final stage
of his plan and that they have to stop
him before it's too late now this scene
is filled with tension and suspense as
the hero is trying to overcome the
overwhelming power of made in heaven
while Pucci taunts them with his Divine
Vision the art and animation are
stunning capturing The Surreal and
chaotic nature of the accelerated time
the music and sound effects are also
fitting creating a scene of urgency and
dread the first appearance of made in
heaven is a great example of how to make
a villain's ultimate move both
terrifying and awe-inspiring and how to
set up the final confrontation between
good and evil in a Bizarre Adventure
[Music]
this
giving hell on Earth a new meaning the
next spot goes to yamamoto's
zankanotachi in the recent bleach
Thousand-Year blood War
[Music]
s
is one of the most powerful and
terrifying abilities in the bleach
Universe it's the ultimate expression of
his Fire based on back though ryujin
jaka which can incinerate anything with
its Flames zankanotachi unleashes the
full potential of yamamoto's ryatsu
creating a blazing Aura around him that
reaches temperatures of 15 million
degrees Celsius which is the same as the
sun's core this makes him virtually
Untouchable as anything that comes close
to him will be vaporized instantly
yamamoto's fight against the fake yuha
is a Showcase of his immense strength
and skill as he uses his four techniques
east south west and North each one has a
different effect such as creating a
Blazing Sword summoning an army of
Undead skeletons creating a world of
flames and enveloping himself in a cloak
of fire the fake uh tries to encounter
his own abilities however he's no match
for yamamoto's overwhelming force and is
eventually defeated by his final attack
zanganotachi North Yamamoto Cuts him in
half with a slash that can destroy all
creation the fight is a testament to
yamamoto's loyalty to the sole society
and is resolved to protect it from any
threat
[Music]
s
revving it up in our next entry we have
denji's First Transformation as chainsaw
man in the anime
foreign
[Music]
one of the most memorable scenes in
chainsaw man is denji's First
Transformation into his hybrid form
denzy a young boy who inherited his
father's death from the Yakuza became a
devil Hunter after fusing with pochita
the chainsaw devil when he's betrayed
killed and chopped into pieces pochita
replaces his heart and revives him as a
human devil hybrid denji then pulls the
cord on his chest and unleashes his
chainsaw Powers ripping and tearing
through the devil and zombies with ease
this seed is both gruesome and
exhilarating as we witnessed denji's
Awakening to his new identity and
abilities along with the brutal fighting
style one would expect from a guy with
chainsaws for arms and head dingy's
First Transformation is also a turning
point in his life for better or worse as
he gains a new purpose and a new
quote-unquote ally in makima a public
safety devil Hunter who recruits him for
her team this transformation is the
perfect introduction to the world of
Chainsaw man and the weird mind of
datsuki Fujimoto
thank you
now an obvious pick for one of our top
spots we have Aaron's founding Titan
form in the final season of Attack on
Titan
Aaron who'd been shot by Garvey managed
to make contact with Zeke and enter the
path where he met yamir the original
founder of all Titans Aaron convinced
yamir to follow him and break free from
the cycle of Oppression and violence
that had plagued her in a descendants
for 2 000 years he also gained access to
the full power of the founding Titan
which allowed him to control all the
Titans and unleash the rumbling a
cataclysmic event that would wipe out
most of humanity outside Paradise Island
Aaron's new form as the founding Titan
was unlike anything we'd seen before
this he had a massive skeleton that
dwarfed even the Colossal Titans and a
long spine that connected his severed
heads to his body his appearance really
was terrifying and monstrous reflecting
his ruthlessness and revolutionary
mindset he also had the ability to see
the past and future memories of all the
attack Titan inheritors which gave him a
sense of inevitability and Destiny
Aaron's transformation wasn't only a
physical change but also a psychological
one he'd become a Godlike being who was
willing to sacrifice everything and
everyone
his Twisted vision of freedom
[Music]
is
and finally for the number one pick gear
5 is Luffy's Peak form and it's based on
his devil fruit which is actually a
mythical Zone type
in gear 5 Luffy transforms into a white
haired Warrior that looks like the sun
god Nika a legendary figure who brings
freedom and joy to people in gear 5
Luffy can bend reality and break the
laws of physics he can also use his
previous gears abilities like inflating
his muscles or compressing his limbs but
with more power and control gear 5 is
Luffy's ultimate transformation and it
makes him one of the strongest
characters in one piece taking
inspiration from rubber hose animation
and various cartoon effects Luffy's
rubber power shine in this gear 5 form
overall the wino country Arc had been a
wild ride but this takes the cake for
the most memorable moment revealing a
new and overpowered form for our
protagonist that also cements this anime
as a staple in the Shonen genre that
keeps evolving for over 20 years since
1999. I can't stress just how hyped this
is
can't piss
and those are my favorite
Transformations from anime released in
2020 to 2023 are there any more that
I've missed what are your picks for
honorable mentions then let me know what
you think in the comments section below
once again thank you rage Shadow Legends
for sponsoring today's video use my link
in the description or scan the QR code
and get started on your raid Journey now
I'm glad to have had you here and thank
you so much again for watching this
video